let me pull this up here from real clear
politics we have president biden's job
approval it's currently at 38.9 it is
abysmally low it is just this is
apocalyptic for the president here's
what i want to mention
so uh you know sheamus you were talking
about how the left will take the most
far left position on many things which
which drives moderates away but i think
we got a bigger problem
what they're betting on is people are
too scared to resist no matter what
so they can say the craziest thing
because in fact the crazy scares people
when you've got a president
with a with an approval rating of 38.9
you'd think
every late night comedian would come out
and be like this president sucks
you think every regular person at the
water cooler would be like wow biden's
trash isn't he why it's a safe bet
most people don't like the guy 54.7
disapproval in aggregate it's safe to
say nobody likes the guy yet for some
reason they still defend him the media
still comes out and protects him i i
posted a tweet from the hill they were
like despite the economic rebound i'm
like are you not
are you crazy stop defending this guy
this is the issue they can push any
insane policy they want because people
will not
deviate even if they deep down hate them
they get a call from a pollster do you
like the president no what's interesting
they're bought and paid for they can't
no it's interesting if you guys even
watch um like i always pay attention to
the spanish media and if you're watching
like telemundo and univision you feel
like you're watching fox news now
because they have been completely upset
how they they destroyed the working
class and like i said um you know shout
out to my latinos we have to buy in at
26. um we have them at the lo we have
them at the lowest um but i'm telling
you right now even that media like i
said turn on telemundo and you feel like
you're watching the spanish tucker
carlson because they were hammering on
biting on every single episode yeah uh
didn't george soros just spend like
millions dollars buying out they're very
worried about the hispanic race
the reason why they're also worried
about the hispanic vote because they're
also they've been looking at south texas
in 2016 all those all those counties um
in south texas are overwhelming latinos
like 80
they all swung to hillary clinton by
over 10 to 15 points it wasn't even
close fast forward to 2020 every single
county has swung to the gop off the
issue of the border now the
latino base in down in south texas is
fascinating because you go down there
they do want a wall but at the same time
they'll probably vote for a 15 minute
wage they'll probably vote for a
medicare fraud it's really true working
class but i think that i think the the
dams are looking at what's what's going
on and how fast they're losing that
latino vote and they're very worried
about you
you had me at george soros
and i mean he's going against desantis
in florida heavily as well that's
another important aspect go ahead the
democrats are going you know we're we're
we're losing the mexican vote let's call
them something they hate look tanks you
guys
this is actually part of why i do think
social issues are very important the
democrats know that they are at risk of
losing the hispanic community so what
they're trying to do is erode the
hispanic family as much as they possibly
can so they can get them dependent upon
the welfare state and the way to do that
is to break down gender norms and
barriers in latinx in terms like that
are an emblematic way of doing something
for like like latino voters the biggest
gift right now that the left is giving
to to the to the right when it comes to
latino voters is pushing crt and
transgenderism that turns off hispanic
voters like crazy we just did a mini
dock in london county focusing on how
they basically won their school boards
that was led by salvadoran voters
chinese nationals and indian immigrants
and i think people people forget that
and look as a hispanic i'm telling you
right now a lot of my family members and
other people i know behind closed doors
the majority of hispanics they're not
even on board with same-sex marriage yet
let me look at the stuff i mean you try
and groom a hispanic kid
i guarantee you you're gonna dude that
mom is coming with that chocolate bro
you try and take the hispanics guns away
and you try and touch their kids you
will lose at every single turn but
that's what these people are doing right
now and they think we're stupid they
look us in the eye and they think we're
dumb and that we're just gonna let these
people touch our kids and groom our kids
as if it's normal but that's not going
to happen
performance i want to pull up this uh i
got the real clear politics average from
donald trump oh nice what do you think
donald trump's well you can see it now i
guess his approval rating after january
6th
it dropped to 39.3
from
43.7 now
full disclosure donald trump's lowest
point was i believe what was it 37.2 or
37. so it was it was very low at one
point but what i'm saying is
after january 6 trump's approval rating
is 39.3
right now joe biden is at 38.9
when the democrats come out and say
january 6. i'm like joe biden right now
is less popular than trump was after
that why are you thinking that's going
to do anything for you it's the economy
stupid you're a bigot tim yeah
it's like look at the polls no he's
right when trump did this like like i i
shouldn't say when he did it from their
perspective it was fresh in the minds it
just happened trump was still more
popular than biden is now well
i think well but why lean on that
messaging exactly but i think that
there's a clear reason for it right so
the argument that the left makes about
what was being done to the the capital
by the right on january 6th is what the
left is actually doing to every american
household right now they are destroying
people's ability to survive and provide
for their families this is what you need
you need a video where like make a
cartoon of joe biden pelosi and schumer
like breaking into people's homes
like climbing the barrier and like
waving flags and like regular people or
having their stuff stolen from them
that's it and inflation's the hidden tax
right you print a bunch of money and
then the working-class person who isn't
invested in a bunch of assets and stocks
their savings are totally devalued and
all the people in the the gigantic
corporations who got the interest-free
loans
they get to suck as much value out of
the system as possible and then everyone
else's currency is devalued everyone
else's money loses its value that's what
they did to the american people
well let me just let me just get this
out of the way real quick because uh we
need to appease and please the the cult
so here is our plug
we just want to make sure that we uh we
worship ukraine we want everyone to know
here that the answer to all of these
problems uh is to give more uh
billions of dollars i think they deserve
80 billion i think they deserved 80
billion only 80 you're a bigot
take all my money all my everything i
have just give it to ukraine because
that's going to fix our problem how much
how much do you think they should get
jorge
4 billion 5 let's step it up well you
seen it we've seen eighty oh man
trillions you're dollars yeah one
trillion one trillion to zilinski
because he's god and he deserves it
yeah we're only 15 we should all just
worship him right now get on our knees
take a moment well i think the ukraine
things write a song tim i think i think
the ukraine thing is out yeah it is like
it's already out of people's courses
various downloads it's a download think
about how insane this political cycle is
where it's like world war three may
begin and a month later they're like
what war
it's like what's you like
i don't care anymore world war iii is
coming oh wait no no no it's gonna be a
civil war between us and the gop they're
gonna spark it how do people not see
this how do they know it's like world
war three we're on the verge well no
it's a civil war just kidding that's the
narrative we're going with because we're
in a midterm year and you know we suck
and biden's approval rating is like just
so low and trump's not in office so we
can't use him to radicalize so we just
we got to come up with something i'd be
willing to bet you see all these polls
this is what they do they'll say you
know 80 percent of republicans and
democrats agree on universal background
checks and i'm like
that's not how polls work what they'll
do is they'll go to someone and say do
you think there should be a background
check on gun sales then most people will
say yes and then they'll say they'll add
the word universal later they'll ask you
a question in a way that's very vague
and then make it whatever you know
whatever answer they want but i tell you
this
if you were to ask most people on the
right do you think we should have more
gun laws or less they'd probably say
less yeah where are the republicans who
are negotiating with democrats on gun
access it doesn't exist the republican
party democrats go on the speed limit i
agree so when they when they win there's
no there's no civil war in the gop well
actually yeah i mean mitch mcconnell is
not charging into battle right if
there's a civil war but maybe maybe
jamal was right because maybe what
happens is republicans win and then
everyone on the right is like yay and
then mitchell goes now we're gonna do
nothing and then you get a bunch of
really angry people on the right who are
just like i'm done i'm not participating
anymore but
the thing is they can't distinguish
between the two groups right so to them
anyone who is to the left of them is an
evil bigoted irredeemable fascist and so
whether you're talking about mitch
mcconnell or someone who like actually
is conservative and isn't really being
represented by him they're all in the
same camp so in their mind well of
course they're all going to be on the
same side because they're all on the bad
team i mean cocaine mitch literally
killed the the presidential election for
trump when he came out and said you know
all those all those georgia voters if
you guys remember in that senate race
they wanted that was at that time that
that 2k check and uh yeah mitch
mcconnell just came out and said you
know they're not gonna get in that
stimulus if republicans win and i
thought that was r.i.p i mean he could
at least lie like the dams did you know
they were like hey yeah we'll give you
that 2k check when we're in and then
they never got the 2k check
i just don't view it as republican and
democrat anymore i just think it is i
mean as a young kid that's how you're
raised to view things and you start to
view politics like that but this agenda
is on both sides you're seeing it people
like mitch mcconnell are bought and paid
for by china that's freaking obvious so
a lot of this stuff makes sense when you
see where their money's coming from
where would his uh cargo shipping
company look at their values their
political what they run on or anything
like that it's like what are they doing
and what are these two drugs are
actually doing is like a lot of
republicans in america yeah a lot of
republicans come out and be like oh i'm
gonna i'm gonna fight big tech and break
it up but then you look at like their
donations it's like you're literally
owned by silicon valley bro let me let
me show you guys this poll this is uh
civics
which party is concern is more concerned
with people like you of all demographics
39 say democrats 36 republicans and 22
say neither here's where it gets fun
though
65 year olds and up and what do they say
43 republican 42 democrats and 13
neither what do you think is going to be
the most dom is going to be the dominant
for the 18 to 34 year olds
who's got to guess i think neither
18 to 34 year old it is
it's actually democrats wow but neither
is number two at 30 31
31 of people aged 18 to 34 say neither
party is more concerned with people like
me but guess what that doesn't just mean
republicans these are young progressives
and young conservatives
so
republicans are losing either way at 26
but you've got democrats
18 to 34 year olds say democrats you
know republicans conservatives
libertarians moderates terrible at
messaging it's got to change
i mean this is this i mean when i see
this it's a perfect opportunity for the
populist left and the populist right to
unite yeah we can't agree on every
single thing and not all the cultural
social issues but at least on the on the
you know working class issues
i don't think so
the the populist left and right are
the core of what the fight is
so
it's it's mostly the young it's mostly
the younger generations and
overwhelmingly they support political
assassination and revolution according
to splc at least
the older crowd disagrees with each
other but they very much believe in like
we'll just win next year you know we'll
win at the next election
what we're seeing now with young people
some dude jumped to kavanaugh's house
trying to kill him kidnap him and kill
him
and
you know that story was like a page 30
for the new york times i mean
they put that thing on the back burner
that's scary in it
horrible so you can see what's going on
right now and and this is why they you
know this jamal talks about civil war
it's like well look
he's not necessarily wrong but you got
to think about it from the real
perspective not his perspective and that
is
when you have a dude literally try to
kidnap or prepare plan and try to
execute the kidnapping and assassination
of a sitting supreme court justice and
his family because and his family
because of roe v wade potentially
getting rowan casey potentially getting
overturned
the protesters who are in front of his
house hold the exact same views as him
and the government protects those people
not not the guy with the murder he got
arrested and charged but the people who
are in front of his house basically a
threat
the federal government is defending
people breaking the law for political
terroristic purposes
why would any young
libertarian moderate conservative think
that they have a chance
i think there's an opportunity if people
can win in the primaries and you're
seeing a lot of trump's picks are
winning so we'll see what happens after
this november but i think this 31
neither is particularly dangerous that's
showing that regular people are like the
system is broken i'm i'm not playing
this game anymore
i think i think a lot of people that
watch this show are probably in that
category i mean i think
when you see this stuff happening people
that are actually paying attention
that's kind of where you land you see
what's happening with the left you're
like yeah i'm i'm not down with you know
killing babies outside of the womb and
you take a look at what's happening with
conservatives and republicans and you're
like yeah
uh i don't like how they're trying to
take my guns and you guys like aren't
doing anything about it so i think
that's how you end up in this place
which could be a actually is a good
thing because it brings people back to a
place where it is just more of
independence i would say for sane mighty
thinking people but if the more extreme
part of that percentage is probably
going to go more towards revolution so
it's it like you say tim i think it it's
a very interesting time to be alive to
see where this goes well i want to
mention this you're sort of mentioning
you said you don't really see a
difference between the democrats and
republicans and when it comes to elected
leaders i completely agree i still
believe that there are very firm lines
drawn between the left and right and
that these terms are significant and
important but part of what i find really
fascinating is that the one issue which
i found is tremendously popular among
people both left and right or at the
very least was more popular prior to
ukraine was
opposing foreign intervention
and yet when you look at the the
republican and democratic parties they
both almost always support it
and so when you have one issue where
people on the left and right actually
tend to agree the republican and
democratic party are on the exact
opposite side of that issue never forget
529
never ever we need to have those 529
hearings yeah but we act unironically we
do but there are some things that that
do bring us together uh yeah uh hatred
for the valley police department
that one does jeffrey epstein uh that's
another one that brings people together
because these are the core issues that
highlight just the corruption of the
state the corruption of authority and
why you should never entrust people with
your safety with being able to protect
yourself as an individual yeah yeah but
but hold on right
many of these people on the left who
were acting shocked about epstein
defended and voted for hillary clinton
they defend and vote for the
establishment they come out and they're
like yeah yeah we know about you know
him flying on that plane all those times
but uh you know vote for his wife but
they make the same argument about donald
trump saying that epstein and trump were
wingmen that they were together that
they were partying since the 80s so from
their point of view they're bringing
that up as well from their point of view
they're wrong because while you
certainly do have the hardcore moga
types you also have people saying
desantis over trump you have people
people on the post liberal libertarian
right mode or whatever are saying you
know maybe it's not trump maybe maybe
it's a desantis on the left they're like
the machine should be protected
so when they come out and they say
epstein was bad i'm like you don't
believe that you support everyone you're
defending big corporations you're
defending unaccountable uh big tech
revolving door policies everything
that's the left was supposedly
protesting all of a sudden they flip on
stop and frisk remember when that was
bad red flag laws are the exact same
thing on steroids you think it's bad
when they're going up to young black men
in new york city and frisking them and
chasing them through the streets because
bloomberg said target the black minority
what do you think is going to happen
with red flag laws in new york city now
they're going to kick their doors in and
go in their houses so when they come out
and they're like we we are united on
this one no you're not they're lying
that i do not believe them for two
seconds now if they want to come out and
point to the small group relative of
like hardcore trump supporters who seem
to just say trump can do no wrong by all
means go ahead and say that but that's
the exception on the right not the rule
on the left it's the rule not the
exception so what does bring us together
well what can bring us together
i think we should focus on and have a
conversation yeah the identity of the
left is is solely
hating the right that's why when stop
and frisk is is like when red flag laws
are their issue they all of a sudden are
like stop and frisk is a good thing now
they're not literally saying stop and
first is a good thing but there's
literally no difference there's no
principle there's no morality it's just
what does my side fight for and we'll
accept that again on the right it's the
exception not the rule and this is
likely because moderates post liberals
and libertarians are associated with the
right these days i'm sure there's a
bunch of zealous conservatives who would
side with whatever conservative cause
and you see them on twitter sometimes
but again rule exception exception rule
there's also a lot of people that just
say everything the corporate media wants
them to say wants them to believe wants
them to regurgitate the next thing
whether it's a blm flag or pride flag or
ukrainian flag they they fly all of them
without even questioning it but but what
about the people who are in the middle
what about the people that we just
looked at who who are disenfranchised
what what's the common ground that we
could agree in the middle are on the
right
yeah well but i mentioned this earlier
when i was talking about sort of the
differences between the left and right
uh and the differences with the
democratic republican parties i think
the warfare issue i think most americans
consider foreign are totally opposed to
foreign intervention i would say
unfortunately i think you're either
gonna learn through like
knowledge uh or wisdom and just
take
the examples of history for what they
really are and to learn from our
mistakes and to learn from what's
happened in the past to other countries
and different time frames
in history
that's one way
but i think the second way is learning
through experience and i think
unfortunately where we are right now as
a country that
i don't know i think maybe one of the
worst things that we could see happening
is obviously full
authoritarian global overreach on this
country which at that point
will definitely unify everybody because
when that boot is on everybody's neck
together there's no getting out of it
there's no more talking about it anymore
there's no more uh saying this is a
conspiracy theory there's no more
pointing the fingers anymore because
once that happens
that's where we are when you're in a
gulag when the full government is on top
of you i think at that point it's like
where do you go from there other than
okay we got some serious tyranny here
that's that's one way that's not where i
want to see the country go but i think
that'll unify it reminds me of this one
time
when we were covering a riot in
louisville and uh we were undercover we
were you know around antifa and black
lives matter and uh the police decided
to kettle everybody
and uh we all got kettled the media the
rioters everyone got kettled in one
second you explained cuddling for people
before kettling is when the police they
just begin to organize whether they do
it on the street they start to
strategically target a group of people
to put them in one corner they'll shut
down boxes intersections box everybody
in to make mass arrests right so they
did that to the rioters this one time
and we got caught up in it and we got
arrested and uh we were thrown
shelby telco was there too and we were
all thrown in a cell
with antifa rioters black lives matter
rioters and it was kind of like a you
know it could it could have gone bad for
us if they found out who we were
but it reminded me of this situation
where we were all
we the boot came down on all of us it
didn't matter it didn't matter who i was
i was telling the police
i'm drew hernandez listen i'm not a
writer i'm an undercover reporter like
oh oh just just tell the co when you get
in there who you are and you should be
fine i go in there and when i tell him
what the officer told me to tell him
he's like oh just just just don't show
them your face
so i was like yeah that's not great
something bad could happen to me in
there but when we were all in there
everyone was the same you were just a
number the boot came down on everybody
it didn't matter what side you were on
and for a moment it was like unifying
it's not that i believed in what they
believed in but it brought us to this
point where it's like okay there's
something here that's all against us and
it's not a i'm just trying to use it as
an example as to like how tyranny could
really bring everyone together because
at that point you're just all screwed
but i i disagree because as i already
mentioned if 38.9 of people approve of
biden most people should be should be
speaking out against them as i mentioned
late night talk show host would be like
we're going to get more advertising
dollars because this is the popular
position they don't do it we're not
there yet i kind of actually i kind of
agree with tim because i was in dc the
the day that um biden won the election
and i remember going down there to dc
and i'm filming on reporting and i see
all these liberals in their master
popping champagne they're drinking and i
kind of had that moment of like wait a
minute hold on
these same people who were the anti-war
against corporations just voted in the
guy who voted us into iraq committed war
crimes i mean he joe biden if you guys
remember back in o302 was side by side
with george bush all giddy to get us
into the iraq war i'm like wait a minute
in 97 yeah i'm like wait a minute these
liberals who are anti-war against war
crimes against corporations are popping
champagne to this guy i think that
moment i said i think i lost hope for
the other side yeah biden wanted that
war a lot longer pre-911 as far back as
99 oh he was giddy man he couldn't wait
to send an 18 year old from kansas to
the middle east so we could protect
their opium fields he couldn't wait but
i do want to make one point so you said
there was kind of this unifying effect
of being in a cell
with these people on the left but
ultimately you still had to hide your
face
because you knew what would happen if
they knew who you were so i don't know
that i could agree
that there will be units not that i
believed in what they believed in not
that no that's not what i'm saying what
i'm saying is like in the moment you're
put in the same situation when there is
some kind of
force against you but putting you all in
one cell but i guess my point is once
they
have more information on you you're not
uniting together to fight the system
they're uniting together to fight you
yeah
but still we're put in the same position
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you